[Music]
the pace of business is skyrocketing
data ingestion rates are growing
exponentially expanding your footprint
and third-party data centers and
increased capex for additional hardware
and staffing is time-consuming and
expensive traditional IT environments
simply can't give you the agility and
speed you need to keep pace with your
competitors if you're looking to bring
your SI p workloads to the cloud
you're in luck both si P Hana and si P
netweaver workloads are certified to run
on IBM cloud fair metal servers improve
your company's agility speed up time to
market increase competitiveness and
better serve your lines of business
quickly redeploy your on-premise
environment to a new cloud environment
for easy and cost-effective scaling you
get all the benefits of cloud power
control scalability flexibility and cost
savings single tenant dedicated servers
packed with enterprise grade power and
security up to 8 terabytes of RAM and
192 cores so you'll experience the same
power and performance you see in your
on-premises data centers when building
your s AP certified bare metal servers
mirrior on-premises environments by
mixing physical servers with red hat or
Susa and virtual servers managed with
vmware the virtualization engine of
choice for SI p deployments manager SI p
landscapes in the cloud through our
customer portal or interact via our API
or CLI you have full control of the
stack with IBM cloud and once your ERP
data is in the IBM cloud you have access
to the world's best suite of AI and
machine learning services powered by
Watson to help you glean new insights
and make new plans using the data you've
already collected interacting with
Watson on IBM cloud is as simple as
connecting the services you need
API and you can use our IBM's provided
SDKs to start finding new hypotheses and
conclusions using the data that you
already use to run your business already
have your hands full but need to get s
AP workloads into the cloud quickly the
IBM cloud managed services team can set
up your landscapes for you or we can
match you with one of our cloud
ecosystem business partners who
specialize in your region industry and
environment for more information go to
IBM dot biz slash s AP servers